My name is Nishant Pattney
Founder and CEO of Hello English Project
This project is an application that helps millions of Indians learn English in a way
A fun and attractive way to design an attractive character that carries games.
I came up with the idea Hello English
When I was studying in China, I was wandering around everywhere and my luggage was on my back
I try to meet my needs as a vegetarian without speaking Mandarin.
Then I realized that it was much harder for me
Indians who try to learn English,
Learning English has become important
For those who want to achieve success in their work today.
India has a remarkable diversity thanks to 22 languages ​​adopted by the government.
English is the preferred language of business
All other large companies prefer to use them.
My name is Brancho Bandari, the co-founder of Hello English
We wanted to make it fun and easy to learn English at no cost
Since learning English is via smartphone
Is of great importance to millions of Indians.
Hello English is compatible with more than 15 Indian languages,
12 languages ​​have support for built-in Android fonts.
One of the main objectives of the application is to help people speak English,
Google's text-to-speech engine helps
In making it very easy to maintain the English accent,
Therefore our weekly retention rates have grown at an average of over 18%.
Users encountered some normal problems initially due to slow Internet connection
And the use of devices with low storage capacity
Power Processing Limited.
So we decided to pay attention to improving our application to address these problems.
We've found that Google has a wide range of tools for developers
Utilizing them to improve applications to suit emerging markets such as India.
We were able to reduce the application size from 16 to 9 MB
Which immediately reduced the rate of uninstallation by 15%.
Most application features can also be used
No Internet.
Today, the number of users exceeds 13 million who want to learn English
On Hello English, not only from India but from all over the world.
We are also expanding geographically to other emerging markets with similar needs
Learn English.
We are very encouraged by the success stories we hear from the beneficiaries
Of the educational content of the application and how our efforts have completely changed their lives.